Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David P..
Last week I said I don't gloat when an anti
VAX person dies of covid, I don't.
We got a really strong voicemail from the
egg man who we haven't heard from for a little
while.
He has a different perspective on this.
Take a listen.
Speaker 5: I do you and Pat keep talking about
the anti and Mike Ashley Bhavin on all these
people are victims and you feel bad.
You have empathy, you feel bad for them.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I have empathy.
I'm sorry, Yagman,
Speaker 5: you call them victims are victims
of misinformation.
Dave, I'm gloating.
And their deaths, just like they gloated in
RBD death.
Okay, here's the deal.
Right.
You have to be proposed for some reason, some
ways to fall for that.
Those those I
Speaker 1: think Agamemnon's predisposed
Speaker 5: facts.
They're victims.
They're victims of their own hatred and racist
feelings.
They're not innocent in this.
You tell two people that the vaccine doesn't
work.
One believes it, one doesn't.
One that doesn't believe it, doesn't believe
it for reasons they already have predetermined
in their own minds, racist, fucked up, hateful
reasons.
So they're not innocent.
You feel so.
But aren't they
Speaker 1: victims because they were indoctrinated
into that is my point.
Speaker 5: Ashley Babbette, she's a horrible
freakin person.
As they say, I'm just saying we need to have
less empathy for them because they have no
empathy for us.
Wow.
Speaker 1: So basically it's like an eye for
an eye from the eggman.
Speaker 5: The liberals will never win if
we feel bad for them and think of them as
victims.
They think of themselves as victims.
And you're feeding that
Speaker 1: the ideology has to be rooted out.
I don't suggest we do anything short of one
hundred and ten percent rooting out the ideology,
but gloating about the death seems like it's
over the line for me.
And I think most people in the audience agree.
We've got a great bonus show planned for you
today.
Texas, Texas State Senate has passed a bill
to remove required lessons about civil rights
movements from the curricula of public schools.
Horrifying.
A Utah pharmacist gave a bunch of people cards
saying they had been vaccinated when they
had not been vaccinated.
And lastly, we are about to see the first
Trump rioter sentenced.
What are we expecting?
What are the charges?
All of those stories and more on today's bonus
show.
Get instant access by becoming a member at
join PACOM dot com.